is a very privileged label right to be
able to say that you're feminist right
and I say that because I Come From A
working class background of Dominican
immigrant parents my mother would not
necessarily identify as a feminist I
looked to my mother and I do think of
her as a feminist a lot of my ideas and
my empowerment comes from seeing her
like survive and put food on the table
when I'm thinking about feminism I'm
always thinking about who's not part of
the conversation what are the barriers
how do we think about Equity how we
think about self-empowerment and agency
and having a voice right and having
choice and thinking about our basic
human rights education access to health
homes like having bread having food and
those things are very important right
and they're at the Crux right about of
what a lot of us here know that we need
it's like there are the barriers right
that we constantly ignore that are very
much systemic